Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley Magnani,
as some are calling her McKenny McEnany.
I don't know how you pronounce her last name,
but by that I mean you personally.
But you know who I'm talking about.
She could barely keep her lies straight yesterday
at a 26 minute press briefing that she gave.
And we have to come to the realization that
they are barely going to even try to hide
their wrongdoing at this point in time.
So when she started doing these press briefings,
I would livestream them and I would sometimes
say, let's do an over under and put it at
three minutes.
Will it take Caylee more than three minutes
to tell her first lie or less than three minutes?
And she told a lie after lie, 20 seconds.
So the next time I streambed one of her press
briefings, I said, let's do the over under
at 20 seconds.
And then she told the first lie within 12
seconds.
So there's not even a point to doing that
anymore.
These are brazenly lie riddled press briefings.
Let's get into what happened yesterday when
we learned yesterday that Donald Trump tweeted
threats to the governor of Michigan about
if you vote by mail, I may not send you aid
money that you need, including for the recent
flooding in Michigan.
We knew that Caylee was going to be asked
questions about this.
And she was.
And one of the questions was a good one, which
is, you know, you've already admitted that
Trump talks to the Michigan governor regularly.
Why tweet a thread about vote by mail rather
than just communicate it directly?
Kaley McEnany said that that's called transparency.
Kelly, how often does the president talk to
director, both her acting director from the
office to go to the acting director of OMB?
Often he just was in the Oval Office with
the president.
So they do speak often.
I don't have a readout of the president's
schedule, but they do speak regularly.
If he wanted to flag to him his concerns about
Michigan, why don't you just tell him instead
of sending a tweet?
Because the president believes in unprecedented
transparency.
And I'm sure you as a journalist are very
eager and excited when you learn about the
president's decision making process in real
time, whether that's on Twitter for me here
up at the podium.
You just said that that was the reasoning
for him expressing his reasoning.
But I'm saying this is that transparent president.
And I think that that's something that you
should be allotting rather than questions
to why he decided to tweet this for President
Macra.
This is truly a mix of 1984 and brave new
world and a totalitarian dictatorship where
facts simply don't matter.
War is peace.
Defeat is victory.
Accusing a governor of a crime on Twitter
without evidence is what they call unprecedented
transparency.
And good for the reporters in the room.
I mean, this is pretty lukewarm praise, but
they kept asking about this issue and Caylee
kept doing this move where she refers them
to the campaign year.
That's really a campaign issue.
You're going to have to talk to the 2020 Trump
campaign about that.
Why is she doing that?
Because the question is about something Trump
said as president about the disbursement of
funds that he manages as president.
Why would that go to the Trump campaign?
And also, Kaley McEnany herself is a lawyer.
Nope, that's for the campaign, which is basically
a way of saying go ask somebody else.
Can you tell us what more specifically the
president thinks the secretary of state in
Michigan is right by sending out these applications
and did the secretary of state.
Georgia also right that law, by sending out
applications for their draft, I reference
you to the campaign.
These are ballot questions that reference
you to the campaign on the president is my
son.
Where's the White House?
So.
Yes, but that's not a campaign question.
That's the president, the United States saying
that question on ballot initiatives that you
have an absentee ballot.
So I would refer you to the campaign on that
front.
And I would note to you that many of those
ballots that are submitted via mail can be
fraudulent.
I cited to the bipartisan study, I can read
it again.
Maybe you weren't paying attention when I
read it the first time, so I'll read it again.
President Carter, a Democrat, not a Republican,
and James Baker concluded that these ballots
remain the largest source of potential voter
fraud.
So if you cast a ballot on visa mail and you
do so fraudulently, that would be an illegal
act.
And I'd point you to that.
And for further, I'd point you to my former
employer, which is the Trump campaign.
And also important, I want to remind you and
I'm gonna become a bit of a broken record
on this vote by mail fraud is mathematically
nonexistent.
Yesterday I gave you the numbers, 250 million
people have voted by mail in the last 20 years.
There are 7 to 8 case, so that's 7 to 8 percent.
There are 7 to 8 cases of vote by mail fraud
per year.
There is way more in-person voter fraud.
Of course, there are more in-person ballots
cast.
But those numbers also are completely insignificant.
This type of what I call retail strategy,
voter fraud is essentially nonexistent.
Do not fall for it.
Now, here's a really Orwellian moment where
Caylee and was asked about Susan Rice.
Susan Rice is Barack Obama's former national
security adviser.
She recently a letter that she wrote, a memo
that she wrote in Twenty Seventeen, which
is exculpatory of Barack Obama in the context
of Obama gate, was recently released.
I told you about it yesterday.
Kelly McCann.
And he does this thing where she has a page
in this notebook with disinformation that
she will turn to whenever a question is asked
that even tangentially relates to something
she has in her book.
Now, that's fine.
That's not I'm not criticizing her for having
notes.
It's called being prepared.
It's called research.
That's OK.
But the thing is, if Caylee hears one word
that relates to her pages, she will turn to
the page and read the page, even if it has
nothing to do with the question.
And in this case, the named Susan Rice was
mentioned in a very specific exculpatory context.
And Caylee turns to her Susan Rice page and
she reads two minutes of unrelated attacks
on Susan Rice.
Sort of sounds like she's arguing that Susan
Rice's letter was just a lie.
And I'm actually going to play the full two
minutes for you.
Normally, I would I would just slice out the
key part.
But what you really need to see, Susan Rice's
name is mentioned.
Caylee turns to a page about Susan Rice, spends
two minutes reading unrelated things about
Susan Rice and then quickly ends the press
conference and leaves.
This is happening at almost every single one
of these press conferences.
Let's take a look.
I apologize for subjecting you to two minutes
of this, but it's important.
And I know you brought up Susan Rice in that
context.
But I'm going to bring her up in another context
that's equally as new newsworthy.
And that is the e-mail that was declassified
from Susan Rice on Inauguration Day, which
is so peculiar.
Set the scene.
It's inauguration day here.
Move out of the White House.
This is the most powerful building on planet
Earth.
Susan Rice is moving out, reflecting on her
time here.
And what is she doing?
She's not packing her boxes.
She's not being nostalgic about her time in
the White House.
What she's doing is writing an email where
three times she writes that President Obama
emphasized to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn.
By the book, by the book, by the book, she
writes it three times.
As Shakespeare said, thou doth protest too
much.
Susan Rice, he didn't have the Susan Rice
part in there, but I'll add that in two, she
was asked specifically about the unmasking
and Michael Flynn after after she discussed
it on January 5th in the Oval Office with
Obama after she wrote this e-mail to herself
on Inauguration Day.
She was asked by a good journalist, Judy Woodruff,
about this e-mail and she said about the unmasking
and Michael Flynn, not the e-mail, but the
unmasking.
She was asked specifically about Nunez's claim
specifically.
So clarify was Nunez's claim.
And she said, I know nothing about this.
So it was a lie.
And then Susan Rice and Stone brought it up
to me.
I will bring it up to you.
Her attorney said that this was the first
opportunity, three weeks after this Oval Office
meeting, that she had to write this e-mail
memorializing her Oval Office meeting with
Barack Obama, discussing Michael Flynn.
It was her first opportunity, she said.
Interesting because she had an opportunity
in those three weeks on January 10th to do
a passing of the baton event with none other
than Michael Flynn, where she praised him,
wished him success, and talked about the great
transition into the White House.
And then on January 12th, she was able to
participate in a story that published on that
date in the lifestyle section of the.
Washington Post She never had time to write
this e-mail and tell Inauguration Day, she's
rushing out the door when in fact she had
an opportunity to do all of those things.
I'll leave that with you.
Thank you for bringing up Susan Rice.
Not in the context that I wished, but for
allowing me to share that with you.
So the reason I played all of that is that
it's really important for you to understand
that this is what they claim is radical transparency.
And it's not of course, it's reading preplan,
talking points and then walking off the stage
before anybody can say, hey, that stuff you
just said has nothing to do with my question.
And the saddest part, the most tragic part
of this is that Trump ists love her.
They think she's doing so well at her job.
She doesn't answer questions.
She does 20 minute press briefings.
Yesterday's was 26 minutes after showing up
30, 40 minutes late.
That it's her speech and her questions, 26
minutes.
She reads non-sequitor material from her notes,
and then she leaves.
And the Trump ists are gleeful because to
them, this counts as strength turning weird.
It's that like yesterday she turned a question
back on a reporter.
Don't you agree?
X, Y, Z.
That's not what a reporter is, therefore lying.
Barely keeping it together.
Attacking the media, walking out abruptly.
That's the state of affairs.
And the Trump lists are thrilled because they
believe she's owning the liberal media.
We live in a very, very backwards country
right now.
Let me remind you, Monday is Memorial Day.
We will be doing a one day huge membership
special.
If you've been thinking about getting a membership
membership, of course, the number one way
to support our show Monday is a perfect day
to do it.
Trump's phone call wasn't perfect.
Monday is the perfect day to get yourself
a membership.
If you want to be notified about the Monday
special.
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman.